young soldiers on tour have it hard
harsh environments and long hours in
poor conditions mean morale can be hard
to keep up at times but essential if the
job is to be done perspectives
sometimes change and things which were
normally seen macabre or dark can
inspire laughter shooting a target with
the opposite leaders image on it with
paint see munitions around may seem
funny whilst in theater and no doubt
relieved the tensions of an operational
stressful tour for a second but I'm
afraid I can't condone it that said I
was no angel when I was in and this is
by no means the worst crime ever
committed they were not plotting a coup
and they never intended the footage to
go viral social media the source to drop
a minute has also amplified the mishap
the lads involved and I do know who they
are but soft operators in a great unit I
don't believe they should be hung out to
dry for this
I genuinely believe the exposure and
embarrassment to their regiment caused
will teach them a lesson I'm probably on
your side I think I think that people do
things they do them for a joke at a
particular time and you know there does
seem to be a bit of an overreaction if
you look at all the tweets and
everything else that's come around
something a lot of people are taking it
terribly seriously some of the words are
seen used have been horrific yeah now
horrific to me is a body with no limbs
left on it or something like that
horrific is not somebody alright they've
had a little bit of a laugh at over
someone's expense but that's not
horrific but there is something that in
amongst it all isn't there I mean why is
why isn't the Prime Minister up there
why is the leader of the Opposition
who's to say if they're to picture the
Prime Minister I wouldn't put it up
there seriously it's serious Phil it's
serious it's because they're very
serious we live in a climate where MPs
and politicians face serious threats to
their safety Joe Cox was murdered during
the brexit campaign we've had an MP
recently who found out that there was a
neo-nazi plot to attack with a machete
this is stuff that is really happening
first of all secondly the armed forces
are which you're so proud
which we're all proud have a high
standard and the reason that we have a
high standard is because we condemn
things like this if we were to diminish
the importance of things like we
wouldn't have it's very important to
hold I know no one is condoning it let's
just rein this back a little bit you
know where the media do you know what
really worries me if these five blokes
had been blown up in a Land Rover in
Kabul last week it wouldn't have got the
same level of attention it has for what
they were doing yeah they are also those
five but God forbid that we came under
attack they would actually put
themselves in harm's way they would take
a bullet to protect Jeremy Corbyn to
resume or whatever many many years ago
when I was a local newspaper reporter I
went to a fire station and the dart
board as years ago had a picture of
Margaret Thatcher I'm not gonna they no
sooner were firefighters gonna throw
darts really at Margaret Thatcher than
these lads or men would shoot and that's
just I'm not I'm not praising it please
but put it in I'm saying can I just
clarify what I'm saying I was actually
going to say I'm not particularly
interested in punishing these particular
soldiers I think it's important we send
a message this isn't acceptable because
we need to have confidence that armed
forces would protect the leader of the
Opposition just let me finish finally
the reason that I think it's important
to analyze not necessarily these
individuals I haven't been calling for
them to be punished or court-martialed
what I'm interested in is the root
causes of why they were doing that
reason me and Sajid Javid say that
Jeremy Corbyn is a threat to our
national security such as Javid said
he's downright dangerous this is the
language of our politicians it is not
acceptable to demonize the leader of the
Opposition plays a crucial role and that
is why we think things can I just hold a
suggestion maybe they chose the
photographs of Jeremy Corbyn because
he's the man who says he's friends with
the IRA effused to condemn the IRA
that's not no one's condoning it we've
all said that claims but what I think is
that you know when you have we have a
Labour spokesman saying this is his
quote this behavior is alarming and
unacceptable I mean it's it's it's
ironic a joke in itself because know
what what what is alarming and
unacceptable is the anti-semitism
within the Labour Party what is alarming
and unacceptable as the leader of the
Opposition praising terrorists being
friends with terrorists that's a lie
this is this is the dark human power we
try and explain dark humor to all right
now there was a book written by by Helen
Parr it's called our boys and it's about
the parachute regiment I think you know
on one of the mountains fighting in the
Falkland Islands and one of the guys
choked so he had to lie down for so long
he might as well have brought a pillow
because didn't matter the income and he
was getting did that mean its humour
that wouldn't you wouldn't normally find
it funny when I was inside where I was
but I was in a West African country and
their work there was it there was
someone who'd been shot and he was laid
on a pile of batteries and somebody
quipped that you better get him off
there because he's gonna ruin his
clothes now that's not funny okay it's
not funny now all right but when you're
actually there
it lightens the load and when you're
seeing honking hideous things on a daily
basis to make light of it helps you get
over it and that's what I'm trying to
get here these guys are just making
light of anything except their lines
that shouldn't be crossed except that
their lines of normal I've never met oh
I've never had many soldiers who are on
the left in our society by and large
soldiers like you take yourself a fairly
right wing position so I'm all middle to
right I don't say I'm far right by any
stretch of the imagination job what you
call middle to right some of us look
cool on what I'm saying that's the only
cuz that's the only concern about this
that it's that if they're not putting up
pictures of some joke they're not
putting up somebody who who the right of
the Conservative Party sees as a real
threat is what they say about ab corbin
and that's the only worrying thing is
social media every single day there are
terrible terrible things written on
there there are terrible jokes there are
terrible things written about Korbin and
to resume and no one does it does think
about it no one turns a head and
suddenly these five guys are gonna be
castigated they're shooting him if we
they're shooting with paint wings
paintball it's not real bullets it's
painful
somebody said on my phone in showed
today we'll tell you what the Ministry
of Defense says in just a moment but
fella want to put this to you someone
who's ex-military said on my phone and
today that there's nothing more
dangerous than bored soldiers absolutely
and that is the reality it's probably
the senior officer I was probably the
senior officers who needed to keep an
eye on what was going on
it's a Ministry of Defence of course
have a pint on this we are aware of
video circulating on social media this
behavior is totally unacceptable and
falls well below the high standards the
army expects and a full investigation
has been launched that's the end of that
as it should what happened to them
they through the grapevine I'm here and
they've probably been removed from Fiat
already so they've already been pulled
from doing the job that they were doing
and doing well by all accounts okay
I don't know I'm hoping that we've
enough public pressure this whole thing
what's happened down I'm not saying they
don't need a ticking off I'm not saying
they don't need a few extras and I'm not
saying they shouldn't put their feet
together in front of the colonel what I
am saying is don't throw the book at
these geezers they are good lads but
they will presumably the worst
punishment for them is they've let the
regiment down to the viewer why you feel
that sort of Brotherhood because they
are so proud so I mean especially the
parachute regiment they are they are
paratroopers frill and through you know
some people would even call these guys
animals sometimes say yes we are animals
but we're good animals you know I mean
they love it they love the job they love
the country they love what they're doing
all right they might have demonized
somebody you know for five seconds in a
little bit of a joke they understand
what the fuss is about you know I think
their operational commitment and the way
that they don't employ themselves into
what they're doing they might be
bothered about breaks at the moment
don't be doing their job that we're
looking after would they understand at
least they share they would do when the
wheel stalls down let's just go
somewhere I don't think from whatever
that's it was ever intended to go viral
it was a snapchat which someone else's
screenshot and subsequently sent out
because they thought it was funny
alright so those dad said never thought
this was going to hit the public was
just it was just I think the ranges that
there were no offices present what do
you think the offices would would they
have recognized that this was pretty
silly thing to do they would of course
they wouldn't know the solutions I think
in the light though most of the soldiers
would have recognized and probably still
recognizes a silly thing to do however
they were relieving some
stress tension and boredom that they
would have experienced at the end of a
very heavy five months six month to
Afghanistan relieving tension of boredom
you know Carol you said this isn't
political it is removed from politics
the the reason this is problematic is
that they chose a political figure who
represents something in our democracy
that is why it is disturbing for people
and to see them using him as it wasn't
political I so when you when you're in
Afghanistan you're so far removed from
politics and what is going on and the
mood of the car you don't get that then
why do you serve it down
I'm gonna put this to bed right now I'm
gonna I'm gonna put it to bed the whole
notion you people over there as well or
I'm gonna put this to bed okay are the
paratroopers that did that any worse
than somebody who would buy one of these
a Jeremy Corbyn hate dog toy and give it
to their animal I mean seriously do not
mean there you go it makes me want to
bite it so come on let's lighten up
about the whole thing
parachute regiment I salute you